[Musica]
cominciamo con una domanda
apparentemente semplice chi di voi in
questo momento crede di stare sognando
alzi la mano abbiamo 12
non tanti per fortuna una seconda
domanda collegata alla prima anche se
apparentemente non lo è
chi di voi si fiderebbe di qualcuno che
vi tradisce
ogni giorno ogni giorno anzi ogni notte
vi inganna facendovi credere cose che
non sono vere
c'è qualcuno che si fiderebbe su questo
siamo tutti coerenti ecco eppure questo
è quello che facciamo di fidarci di
qualcuno che ci inganna tutti i giorni è
quello che facciamo tutti noi perché
siamo ingannati dalla nostra mente
ogni giorno ogni notte quando dormiamo
per mediamente un'ora e mezza
questa è la durata delle cosiddette fasi
rem quella in cui noi sogniamo
nel mentre dormiamo dormiamo qual è
l'esperienza del sogno lo sappiamo tutti
crediamo a quello che vediamo se siamo
in un incubo abbiamo paura perché quel
mostro che ci insegue crediamo che sia
vero
se abbiamo un affaire con qualcuno ci
crediamo e quella esperienza che viviamo
la viviamo intensamente la nostra mente
ci inganna in una maniera estremamente
convincente che coinvolge tutti i nostri
sensi coinvolgere la vista coinvolge
l'udito coinvolge il tatto coinvolge le
emozioni il nostro server
nella nostra mente producono per noi
quando sogniamo delle specie di film di
di realtà virtuali naturali qualcuno di
voi avrà cominciato a utilizzare l'altra
virtuale no cosa succede
siamo immersi ci crediamo nel sogno
ancora di più è una tecnologia diciamo
naturale ancora più efficace
eppure durante la giornata quando siamo
svegli ci fidiamo della nostra mente che
è la stessa che ci ha tradito nella
notte è la stessa che ci ha ingannato o
magari ci ha ispirato durante la notte
ma pur sempre generando qualcosa che non
è vero e costruito e illusorio e
un'ombra vedete questa idea che la
nostra mente ci inganna attraversato
tutta la nostra cultura occidentale in
una maniera molto profonda generando due
approcci due modi di pensiero
estremamente importanti per tutti noi
non potremmo essere qui adesso
se non avessimo posto in dubbio la
natura ingannatrice dei nostri sensi una
di queste discipline la scienza con il
metodo scientifico la scienza intende
andare oltre i limiti della mente
individuale l'inganno dei nostri sensi e
per quello che usiamo un metro
se io ad occhio dico è quella cosa è
lunga un metro e mezzo so che posso
ingannarmi la mia mente non è precisa ho
bisogno di usare uno strumento che mi
dia una misura oggettiva di quella
lunghezza è così e per tutto nell'ambito
scientifico noi formuliamo dei modelli
ma non ci fidiamo
dobbiamo fare degli esperimenti dobbiamo
prendere delle misure per far sì che
quella nostra idea quella nostra
fantasia venga in qualche modo
confermata dalla realtà esterna e quindi
il metodo scientifico ha ben presente
che la nostra mente ci inganna e non
conta il parere di un singolo scienziato
perché quello di indagare sitra
sbagliato avrà fatto gli esperimenti
diciamo solo in una certa direzione
bisogno dell'altro scienziato dell'altra
scienza
che metta in discussione certi di
falsificare quello che il primo
scienziato la prima senza aver formulato
un altro approccio che fortemente tiene
conto della natura ingannatrice dei
nostri sensi è la filosofia occidentale
c'è anche quella orientale ma abbiamo
più familiarità con quella occidentale
pensate a cartesiano rendete car grande
filosofo francese uno dei padri del
pensiero moderno lui parte nel suo
studio filosofico nella sua esplorazione
filosofica proprio dal dubbio fondante
sulla veridicità dei suoi sensi e cerca
di trovare un punto solido al di qua dei
sensi su cui poi dopo poter costruire un
sistema filosofico e quindi lui parte
con il cogito dello sul famosissimo
vedete scienza e filosofia e vari
approcci filosofici che adesso non
esponiamo hanno ben presente la natura
illusoria dei nostri sensi ma noi come
individui poche volte ci chiediamo
durante il giorno sto sognando oppure no
e invece crediamo a quello che i nostri
sensi costantemente ci fanno vedere
sentire ascoltare toccare
vorrei però sottolineare con voi adesso
un particolare metodo che noi possiamo
utilizzare per diventare più consapevoli
della natura ingannatrice dei nostri
sensi
e questo avviene proprio nel mentre
sogniamo cioè realmente siamo in un
sogno normale cercare di coltivare la
capacità di chiedersi se quello sia un
sogno oppure no
cioè io sono per esempio in seguito da
questo mostro di un incubo
e nel mentre sto scappando mi fermo
contempla la situazione e chiedo ma
questo è un sogno oppure no e mi giro
verso il mostro
è un passaggio di coscienza estremamente
difficile non è facile però forse
qualcuno di voi ne avrà avuto esperienza
qualcuno di voi forse verrà fatto un
sogno in cui sente che è un sogno e
forse riesce a un pochino a dirigerlo si
tratta di sogni prede uccidi i sogni
lucidi un'esperienza estremamente
intensa in cui noi siamo pienamente
consapevoli del fatto che ci troviamo in
un sogno
vedete questa esperienza a me è capitata
da adolescente perché un po praticavo
così maldestramente tecniche di
meditazione durante il giorno e una
notte
mi è capitato di fare un sogno lucido di
questo tipo è estremamente intenso che
ne ha trasformato diciamo nel modo in
cui io vedevo e ancora oggi vedo la
coscienza e la consapevolezza col primo
sogno poi immediatamente riportato
sull'agenda dei sogni lucidi ha
costituito il primo passo di centinaia e
centinaia bisogno di un cd che ho fatto
nella mia vita e continuo ancora a fare
e che hanno un grosso potere
trasformativo inizialmente con i primi
sogni si impara un po a giocare no una
prima cosa per esempio che facevo era di
alzarmi qualche cm da terra quindi
cercare di sfidare le leggi della fisica
e spostarmi da un luogo all'altro di
questa realtà onirica estremamente
dettagliata scivolando
ma poi perché fermarsi a quello quindi
nei sogni successivi mi alzavo di più e
passavo anche attraverso le pareti avevo
la possibilità di volare sopra le città
possibilità di andare da una città ad
un'altra sempre con estremo realismo
incontrare persone che il nostro mondo
onirico genera per noi le persone del
sogno non le possiamo controllare sono
dotate di una strana indipendenza di
pensiero ma noi possiamo decidere di
andare da loro possiamo trasformare il
nostro corpo perché ci si ritrova con un
corpo di sogno che è quello tipico della
veglia
ma se noi guardiamo le nostre mani
bisogno
possiamo come uno sforzo di lucidità e
di consapevolezza trasformarle sei dita
dieci dita con le mani di un animale
diventare un lupo è possibile diventare
un aquila non solo volare e ma anche
avere il corpo di un aquila è possibile
trasformarsi un cane in una donna se
siete un uomo in un uomo siete una donna
è possibile stare i due posti
contemporaneamente essere cosciente di
essere in due luoghi e perché no anche
tre luoghi non è capitato una volta di
essere in tre luoghi diversi uno stava
volando un altro camminare un altro aero
fuso con un pavimento non è stato tanto
tanto piacevole ma interessante e in
ogni caso voi siete in controllo potete
svegliarvi in qualsiasi momento
ecco dicevamo la filosofia e ci sono
varie tracce di questa capacità della
nostra consapevolezza di spostarsi nel
mondo delle ombre è uno dei meeting che
più rende questa idea è un famosissimo
mito che sono certo che molti di voi
avrete sentito ho studiato e il mito
della caverna di platone l'allegoria
anche della caverna viene chiamata anche
così ed è questa storia che sintetizzo
scritta da platone 2400 anni fa nella
repubblica in cui siamo in una grotta
nelle profondità della terra e ci sono
dei prigionieri incatenati che sono
costretti a guardare solo sul fondo
della caverna non hanno la possibilità
di spostarsi e guardarsi indietro
quello è il loro mondo
dietro di loro allora insaputa c'è un
enorme fuoco e tra il fuoco e i
prigionieri ci sono delle persone che
passano con degli oggetti
quindi i prigionieri vedono sul fondo
della caverna delle ombre che si
spostano quella era loro realtà e
credono quindi che quella sia tutta la
realtà quelle ombre sono tutto ciò che
c'è un giorno succede che uno di questi
prigionieri
viene liberato dalle catene si ritrova a
poter uscire da quel suo mondo limitato
la prima cosa che fa vede che c'è un
enorme fuoco e vede che ci sono degli
oggetti tridimensionali di cui prima non
aveva assolutamente idea e capisce che
le ombre che prima pensava essere gli
oggetti del mondo sono solo una
proiezione della realtà degli oggetti
primi menziona lì poi in lontananza vede
una luce che è l'ingresso della caverna
in cui aveva vissuto fino ad allora vi
si dirige esce fuori e vede che il mondo
è molto più complesso e molto ricco
pieno di colori pieni di luce e c'è un
grande fuoco molto più grande di quello
della caverna che il sole che illumina
tutti gli oggetti e con questi può
interagire può correre può toccare le
cose così risvegliato questa vedete una
metafora del risveglio però fa un altro
passaggio che è quello che avviene anche
nel sogno lucido cioè dal risveglio
decide di tornare nel mondo delle ombre
ritorna giù nella grotta dove ci sono i
suoi compagni ancora prigionieri e vuole
con essi comunicare che la realtà delle
ombre non è la vera realtà ma c'è una
realtà molto più complessa molto più
ricca micro più bella punto più vera
esterna vedete i miti sapete descrivono
dei processi mentali
così come i sogni infatti miti e sogni
si sovrappongono ad uno stretto legame
in questo mito di platone c'è questo
movimento mentale del risvegliarsi un
processo
duro anche che all'inizio è difficile
svegliarsi perché siamo accecati dalla
luce ma poi piano piano ci svegliamo
completamente ma poi vedete c'è questo
secondo passaggio che il ritorno al
mondo delle ombre il ritorno al sonno il
ritorno alla condizione illusoria in cui
si cerca di interagire ma da risvegliato
quindi vedete come uno svegliarsi ma nel
sogno la ricerca scientifica negli
ultimi anni neuro scientifiche si è
concentrata su questo fenomeno
prima era appunto più appannaggio della
filosofia o di qualche aneddoto
raccontato quella poi è diventato uno
studio della psicologia e adesso
addirittura anche delle neuroscienze
quindi cosa succede nel cervello che sta
sognando lucidamente il messaggio è
questo che noi abbiamo una parte del
cervello che è molto importante si
chiama la corteccia prefrontale e quella
che abbiamo dietro la fronte e potete
immaginare il suo ruolo come quella di
essere un po il direttore d'orchestra di
tutte le nostre capacità mentali e
quella che dirige la visione che che
decide quando dobbiamo prestare
attenzione a cosa dobbiamo prestare
attenzione nel nostro campo visivo
quindi il direttore dell'orchestra nel
senso che non suona uno strumento di per
sé ma regola
diciamo le produzioni di tutti gli altri
strumenti e quindi un po i boss o la
boss della nostra mente
ecco quando noi facciamo dei sogni
normali ordinari la corteccia
prefrontale e spenta mentre tutto il
resto del cervello è normalmente attivo
quasi come se fossimo svegli quindi un
cervello molto attivo tranne che per la
corteccia prefrontale quello che si è
scoperto è che quando facciamo un sogno
lucido evento rarissimo difficilissimo
da studiare nei laboratori la corteccia
prefrontale comincia a essere attiva non
pienamente come se fossimo svegli ma in
molte parti sostanziali e più attiva
consuma più ossigeno si è anche visto
che chi ha più propensione per il sogno
lucido o ha sviluppato questa capacità
di essere cosciente nei suoi sogni a una
corteccia prefrontale più doppia più
spesso lo possiamo misurare con
risonanze magnetiche a indicare quindi
una maggiore predisposizione a essere il
direttore d'orchestra diciamo attivo ad
avere un direttore d'orchestra attivo
nella propria mente tanti studi
tantissimi sono ancora in corso e un
argomento di ricerca estremamente
recente la corteccia frontale è il mio
argomento diciamo di ricerca preferito
quindi da tanti anni mi occupo di come
la corteccia prefrontale
regola e dirige il nostro comportamento
allora cosa possiamo fare se vogliamo
aumentare questa nostra capacità di
essere coscienti nel sonno nel sogno una
delle tecniche proprio quella di
chiedersi anche da svegli se stiamo
sognando oppure no cioè così
improvvisamente o sognando oppure no
fare più che desse una risposta porsi la
domanda mettere un po il dubbio sul
fatto che quello che stiamo vedendo sia
la realtà oppure no se sia una nostra
proiezione oppure è un dato di fatto
oggettivo farlo più volte durante il
giorno ci fa
diciamo incorporare una sorta di
abitudine per cui potrebbe darsi che una
di queste volte che ce lo chiediamo in
realtà stiamo sognando realmente e per
cui sto parlando con qualcuno nel mio
mondo di sogno e mi fermo un attimo di
come sto realmente parlando con questa
persona
la storia mente guardando un ted top
oppure è un sogno e cercare di porsi una
domanda e una risposta valida
facendo questo più volte durante la
giornata ma non per rifugiarsi in un
mondo di sogno attenzione è esattamente
il movimento opposto e per diventare più
pienamente consapevoli e lucidi e
presenti in quello che stiamo esperendo
facendo così possiamo diventare dei
sognatori lucidi esperti e che vantaggio
ne abbiamo nella nostra vita da svegli
da pensate una situazione in cui c'è un
evento negativo che vi accade so siete
licenziati brutto oggettivamente brutto
ma quanta proiezione di negatività c'è
su un evento così oggettivamente brutto
incominciavano ad auto svalutarsi perché
hanno licenziato me non meritavo di
avere quella posizione non ho mai
diciamo mostrato di essere bravo su
quello su quell'auto non ho più
possibilità a cosa penseranno di me i
miei familiari
tutto questo vedete come un sogno di cui
che noi mettiamo è un vestito bisogno
che noi
mettiamo addosso ai fatti reali e
concreti allenassi al segnale
decisamente aiuta a distinguere ciò che
è fatto da ciò che nostra proiezione e
in questo modo possiamo vivere meglio
non per rifugiarci in un mondo distante
ma per essere più presenti nei fatti e
quindi diventare più simili al
prigioniero liberato della caverna di
platone e poter andare in giro fuori nel
mondo esterno illuminato dal sole o
anche ritornare nel mondo delle ombre
senza lasciarci catturare da queste e
quindi vi saluto con un augurio di buon
risveglio nei sogni
[Applauso]